Before we get started,
I have a confession.
This is my first attempt at a sock
in the round. I've really never
understood the appeal. Seaming up a sock
is it a problem for me.
But I get it, lots of knitters like
to avoid having a seam in their socks.
OK.
Like every first attempt,
I made every mistake in the book,
but I hope the lessons I learned will help
you avoid these mistakes when
you try a seamless sock.
This is my preferred method, and I'll
offer a few options for you to try.
The basis of this sock is tubular
knitting with the ribber.
Before you start knitting,
be sure that you can knit in the round.
Check your manual and do a little
test knitting before starting.
I was so sure that I knew the carriage
settings on this machine.
But it took me three toes and three
tries before I got it right.
So before you start knitting, please do
a little test swatch of circular knitting.
Here's the goal,
we're going to combine hand and Machine
knitting for a seamless sock.
Starting with a Short row toe,
I'll switch to knitting in round
with my ribber.
I'll add some provisional stitches
for an after-thought heel
and then scrap off in the round.
I'll pick up the cuff and knit in
ribbing on double-point needles by hand.
Then I'll use those same hand knitting
needles and knit the heel by hand.
Let's get started.
I'm going to assume that you
know how to short row a toe.
Here is my green crochet cast-on rag
and a row of blue ravel cord
and I've knit one row of my sock.
I'm using my single bed carriage.
I'll start working my short rows
to form the heel. Short row decrease.
Then Short row increase.
And here's my little toe pouch.
These live stitches are going
to end up on the ribber.
I don't know about you,
but the thought of raising the Ribber
right now and hanging those live
stitches on the ribber needles,
it doesn't sound like fun to me.
So instead, I'm going to hang those live
stitches on the main bed,
doubling up the stitches for now.
When all of the stitches are
on the needles, I can remove the ravel
cord and the waste yarn or
in my case, my cast-on rag..
I'm going to be knitting
in the round with my ribber.
As you know, we need lots of even weight
when we're knitting on the ribber.
I'm using this triangle weight hanger.
You could hang a regular Ribber Cast-on
comb and just poke it right
through the knitting.
You have to play with this a bit,
but make sure that you have good
weight on both pieces of the knitting.
Next, I'll swap out the main bed pressure
plate assembly for the
Ribber connecting arm.
With the weight in place and the stitches
secure,
I'll raise my Ribber.
And rack it to "P" so the needles are
directly across from each other.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is only temporary when we start
knitting, the Ribber needs to be racked
to "H" or those needles are
going to crash into each other.
Guess how many times it took
me to remember that one?
Here's the fun part,
transfer that second set of stitches
from the main bed needles down
to the ribber.
I tried a bunch of different methods for
transferring those individual stitches.
Use whatever method works for you.
Notice how having the Ribber needle's
aligned with the main bed needles
makes it easier to transfer.
This whole process seems tedious,
but there really aren't that many stitches
and repeat after me,
no seam ...No seam ...No seam.
As I mentioned before,
this seems easier to me than trying
to pick up stitches from the scrap and
hanging them up directly on the ribber.
You might disagree.
Once all the stitches are on
the ribber, take time to put all
the stitches on both beds in the hooks
of the needles, align the needles.
Make everything neat and tidy.
Trust me, take time to do this.
And don't forget to rack to "H"
the needles need to alternate so they knit
and they don't crash into each other.
Back to the weight issue,
you'll probably want to use wire weight
hangers on the edges so the edge stitches
knit properly as you knit in the round.
Whew... after hitting the toe and taking
time to transfer the stitches twice.
I hope you practiced tubular knitting
and you don't have to start 3 times
like I did. With the Ribber racked to "H"
the carriages joined and threaded
Knit in one direction on the main bed
and slip on the ribber.
Then knit on the ribber and slip
on the main bed. Knitting in the round.
And do this for the length of the foot
of the sock all the way to the heel.
Now, here's where you have some options.
Theoretically, you could short row shape
the heel of the sock now on the main bed.
You could leave the Ribber stitches
in place, set your Ribber to slip
and shape a heel on the main bed.
Stitches only.
If you've ever knit a Short row heel or
toe, you know that it takes a lot
of weight and those stitches tend to
misbehave as the short row pouch grows.
If you have kept the stitches
on the ribber,
you'll need to reach up underneath
and hang lots of weight or stand on your
head to make sure that the
stitches knit correctly.
I took the easier way out.
When it came time to knit the heel,
I manually knit a provisional
row with Ravel cord.
I didn't use all of the needles
on the main bed, I just left
a couple of needles on each side.
And then I used some clips to secure
the ends of the Ravel cord.
With that provisional row in place,
I continued knitting in the round
right over those stitches.
To finish the foot of my sock,
I switched to some scrap yarn and then
scraped off by knitting in the round.
Voila,
a short row toe and a tube with the blue
provisional row ready for the after-
thought heel and live stitches.
I went outside, turned on some music,
poured a glass of wine and picked up
those live stitches on my double points.
I removed the scrap yarn and
knit a little ribbing.
The blue provisional stitches are
sitting there waiting for heel.
Again, I picked up the live stitches,
removed the ravel cord
and hand knit the heel.
OK, it's an ugly pointed heel.
Blame it on the wine.
Could I have hung those provisional
stitches on the machine and Short
row shaped the heel on the machine?
Sure.
But as I mentioned before,
I'm not a fan of struggling.
How about you?
OK, it's really an ugly sock,
but there are no seams,
and hopefully it will inspire you to try
adding circular knitting
to your sock knitting skills.